Thank you, general, that was very kind of
you, hi, everyone, I'm Brad Bouse as Jen said,
I'm from Seattle.
Seattle is the city in the northwestern corner
of the United States, we have a lot of coffee,
we have a lot of men with beards, we have
a lot of tattoos, and we have a lot of rain,
I feel really at home here in Berlin, it's
great.
I work as a front end engineer, products manager,
mostly for very early stage start ups, I like
figuring out what should and should not be
in a product.
So, I have a little bit of advice for you.
Now, I just want to clear something upright
now, I know that there's been rumors, this
is actually not about the Apple Watch.
I know the timing kind of worked out that
that might be what it's about, it's actually
something different.
Marking something useless sounds, it's a funny
thing to say, maybe that's why you're here,
it's not how we think about things, we normally
think about things and their utility, we've
learned a lot of really useful things to day,
I don't know if that's always the best idea.
So, there's one question that as professional
developers, engineers that you've been asked,
be asked by your boss, your product manager,
your client.
And that question is how long will it take?
And, if you're like me, that's your answer.
And if you're really like me, and then you
just want to tell them to go away.
You have to deal with this problem, the reason
why this causes us a lot of anxiety is that
we have to distill all the come collated things
that could go on in this product, in this
feature, in this bug all the things that could
go wrong, we have to distill that down to
a number, have to turn that to a date, we
have to commit to it, every decision we make
along the road we have to meet that number
this is how we solve problems professionally.
We put them into a mechanism that managers
times, manager chunks of problems to land
the project in finish state, sometimes down
the road.
And along the way we have to make a lot of
compromises, we have to keep saying, oh, we
can't do this, we can't do that, because we
don't have a lot of time that's okay, that's
how it works, with eve got to make money‑‑
we have to make money, business has to go
on, the one thing that this does is it stops
us from exploring code, it stops us from playing
with code.
The reason I want you to do something useless,
take a little bit of time and do something
where there's no dead line where nobody cares
if it's finished.
This is the waterfall swing.
They have been doing well with this, tail
brought it around to different installations
in different cities, and this just looks fun.
If you‑‑ if you, I would really rather
be there right now, in fact.
If you ride this and you're not giggling like
a little schoolgirl, you're just not human,
it looks like a lot of fun.
So what this is called, broadly speaking,
is creative coding.
It's a little bit of problematic term because
it has a gait in coding, yee creative coding
is a qualifier, yee creative is a good thing,
if you don't feel like you're creative, can
you do yee creative coding? That's a problem
I'd like to talk about, that's what I'd like
to work through today.
So the first thing is Iv to say is don't be
afraid I've been talking about yee creative
code for a while, and a lot of people say
that's really neat, but it's not for me, I'm
not yee creative, I'm not good at that, my
stuff doesn't look good.
I can't do that.
That's okay.
It's really natural.
When mess of you think ant art, you probably
think about something like this‑‑ think
art you probably think about this, this is
a masterpiece, Rembrant, he looks like a million
bucks, it probably is way more than a million
bucks, he's worth multiple million bucks,
if you're like me, you might have sat down
and try to draw something, maybe you tried
to draw this? (Laughing) and I'll admit, like
I, I didn't draw that, I Googled it, I took
a terrible child's drawing because I was too
embarrassed of my own bad drawing to put it
on screen.
This is kind of my favorite illustration of
the problem.
And it's what you see all over the place where
experts will give you a tutorial where it
starts to go, way, way, way too fast.
And when you're an expert you never see all
these geniuses you never see all the crap
that they actually make.
You never see their process when they're making
art.
You just draw the rest of it out.
So Ira glass is an American talk show host,
he has a great talk about this very problem.
He said asacriative person the first thing
you probably have is taste, you know kind
of what's good, what's bad, and you have an
opinion about the way things should be, when
you sit down to make something for the very
first time, you make it, you're disappointed
you know your taste is work against you, you
know this stuff is not as good as what you
see out there, what you like, he call this
is the gap.
I think that's‑‑ everybody faces this,
and the only way to cross this grab is with
practice, you have to take a step back, recognize
that I'm at this gap, and I can cross it,
I can cross it by doing work.
Put in practice, I can put in time, I can
work on this process.
This is Chuck Close, he is an American artist,
this was in 1968, I believe.
His quote that I really like, inspiration
is for amateurs the rest of us just show up
and get the work.
Chuck Close is an artist that believers in
process, he believe in doing work.
This is actually a huge painting.
It's an 8‑foot by 8‑foot painting, it's
glorious to behold, if you get a chance to
see it please do, each whisker is beautifully
render, the bouquet around his face, it's
a luminous painting.
And he puts in the work.
And he's actually made a career out of these
extremely photo realistic large form pictures.
And you can see his style evolves you can
understand this is a man that's showing up
to work, he's putting in the hours and he's
making great work.
I don't what his first work started out like,
but I imagine it evolved and he got better.
Maybe he started out drawing the two little
circles, I don't know.
So what this‑‑ when I see this, we like
to think kind of culturally as artists as
being struck by a lightening bolt, maybe they're
lounging on a hill somewhere, they're struck
by a lightening bolt of sudden inspirery inspiration
and they paint the Mona Lisa, whatever, whatever
is an amazing piece of work, but that's not
the case, they're men, they're women, they're
working, they're struggling and they're putting
in the hours, showing up for work, working
on a process, and when you're feeling bad
about whatever you're markinge, think about
process as your savety net, know that if you
keep working at it.
You'll get better.
The reason why you want to keep working when
you're trying to make something is great ideas
are really hidden.
There's a theory I really like strew art Kaufman
it's about adjacent possible.
It's about evolution, we think about evolution
as a linear path where we went straight out
of the muck to bee become Homo sapienses,
that's not how it worked, it was a lurching
process, one evolution beget another evolution,
by the time we got to a third evolution it's
a completely different space from where we
started.
Ideas work the same way, if you're exploring
an idea, a project, you don't know what's
going to happen right away, you have to work,
put in the hours and maybe you'll see something
new that will happen.
We have this in our own live in start ups,
it's called a five pivot.
Sometimes it's a cover for something else,
the classical use of pivot, they explore a
space, they see something else is Bert that
they didn't see before and they move into
it.
So if you combine these two things, idea of
working a process of crossing the gap and
exploring where you are at every stage youv
a powerful mechanism to make something new
and interesting.
Now, it's important for me to say, that I'm
not an artist, I'm not particularly blessed
with creativity, what I am good at is streamlining
processes, I'm good at understanding how things
work, but as you see I'm married to an artist,
this is Anne‑‑ she is a poetty professor,
I have been to far more than my share of poetry
reading, performance arts museums and all
strange things, I feel as an ambassador from
strange lands to share what I've learned as
an engineer.
We work on projects together.
This is one project that we did, it's called
between page and screen.
And it is an augmented reality book of poetry.
I know.
When you open it up you'll see that you have
markers, there's no words, just a series of
markers.
And the instructions to go to between page
and screen.com.
Question see me in many ways, when we hold
up‑‑‑‑ we hold the words in our
hands, and what these are is a series of letters
between page and screen about their kind of
tack curious relation ship.
(fracturus) that's been a successful project
for us.
She's been invited to fly around the world
to present it, she does a much better job
than I do.
This was great, it was a lark, a thing that
we did for fun.
People like it, it's a real book, you can
buy it.
One of the great things that came out of it
a small arts group approached us to do a commissioned
project, which means that we were paid artists,
that was really exciting for us.
Now it was a tiny amount of money, it counts,
right, as paid.
So we started the process with this group,‑‑
Whoa‑‑ don't get excited.
All right we started the process with this
group, ignore that.
And started to look a lot like work.
And we got that question, how long will it
take? How long will it take us to finish this
project, when can we deliver it.
We've arranged the gallery space, figure it
out, start marketing, started to feel a lot
like work.
And the thing is between page and screen never
felt like work, this is the first demo that
we did.
I showed her the library that did the marker
technology, she thought that was cool, we
talked maybe we codo a book, we did this with
a little pig on a piece of paper, we showed
it to a few people and they thought that was
cool and before we knew it we had a book.
Now we have this whole other project and we
have a deadline and it's stressful.
We decided to do a project where we had diaries
from 1858, shopkeeper's diary told a very
interesting story.
She extracted‑‑ transcribed some of
the entries, we decided we would have a project
with the leap motion of where you would go
to a gallery, you would see the leap motion
on a column, and then you would see a monitor
above it that is not as large as this one.
And then as you approached you would see your
own distorted face and when you waved your
hand over the leap motion you would see there's
another text within it.
This is called an erasure.
And this is all done in JavaScript with particles
so there are about a million particles that
are moving around my hand.
And we have thirty different entries that
you can go and you can read.
Of (applause) thank you, that's very kind
of you, and actually it's really hard for
me to show that project because I don't think
it's as good as what it could be.
It doesn't have the same pop that between
page and screen has.
People when she showed between page and screen
there's an O O Oh in the audience, this one
doesn't quite have that.
The reason I feel the deadline really paralyzed
me.
There was a lot of new technology that we
needed to learn.
Every one of these blessed technology had
some problem or another in doing this, and
every time I was faced with solving this problem
I had to make compromises because we had a
deadline.
That's okay, that's how stuff works, that's
how business works, it made me think about
this problem of time and what it does the
creative process.
I realized one thing people like to do is
go up and they like to see themselves reflected.
I thought that was pretty cool, I realized
with this big plate of software that I had
I could do a new project.
I could reuse that rendering pipeline and
do something I call glitch booth and what
that takes very bad selfies.
So, as you see it's kind of like a Skype call.
(Laughing) and there are different things
that you can do and then if you find one that
you like‑‑ you can‑‑ can tweet
it.
So, that's glitch booth and this was that
was about ten hours of code, maybe fifteen
hours of code.
I spent more time ton logo, the site, registering
the Twitter, doing all that stuff then I spent
on writing the code.
I think this is a great example of the adjacent
possible.
There's no way I would of sat down and made
glitch booth, it's a bit of a trivial project,
but since I had the code lying around it was
fun.
I brought it to cascade yeah JS and a lot
of people came up and took pictures and tweeted
it.
It was a lot of fun.
And you can see that now you can see‑‑
there are about 90 of them, it's a Twitter
account.
So that's a little bit of my work, and now
it's your turn, so I want you to make something
useless.
The first thing you'll find as a diligent
conference goer, you're going to go home and
say brad wanted me to make something useless,
and I'm going to do that, and you'll find
that blank pages are blockers, the hardest
part about getting started is getting started
you have a blank page.
That's not a new problem, one thing that artist
do is use rules to get started.
They're called constraint, a really common
constraint is a Haiku, it's a three line poem,
first line has five syllable, seven syllables
and five syllables in the United States we
have school children do this, the form is
so restrictive it becomes a game you have
to fit what ever your mess ermessage is into
this tight format.
Instead of a blank verse assignment they give
them a Haiku, the kids get it done and they
learn a little bit about poetry.
So we actually have, we're blessed with this
enormous network of con train based writing,
I guess you call it Twitter.
This is a Haiku Bot that finds completely
inane tweets and recognizes that they're in
a Haiku formaillot and tweets them as such.
They're actually kind of entertaining.
I everyone in has their favorite dots, this
one's mine, art assignment Bot, pulling a
list of three different tasks, the task, the
theme and then a deadline, and they're great.
I love the constructed D print critiquing
fear due in two seconds.
So,Bots are a great place to start, because
they use the tools you already know how to
use.
They're all based with text, if you know a
little Regx X if you pull from a list, use
an API, osseter, you're Godden.
Then there's a built in audience once you
tweet it and there's a built‑if data set
that is always changing there, are fun things
you didk do with that.
If if text isn't your thing this is Sol Lewitt.
Considered the father of conceptual art, he
is most famous for wall drawings.
The wall drawings are just instructions, instructions
for how to generate the drawing.
And what you have here is the text, the instructions
for the image that you see be hind it.
Basically says place 50 random dots on the
wall and then connect them all.
So if you want to have your own Sol Lewitt
you hire drafts people, official certified
Sol Lewitt people to come out.
They will put it on your wall and you'll get
a certificate, and you now own a Sol Lewitt,
this is a conceptual piece, you never meet
Sol Lewitt certificate.
He's dead, you can still get a new Sol Witt
just for you.
This is part of the concept.
When I saw these instructions I thought it
looked like a ticket from a PM.
And so I made a repository, no idea if this
is legal or not, it hasn't been shut down
yet.
I have several dozen of the instructions,
you can go there, there are templates using
paper J S using processing, if there's a graphic
language you particularly like, we can make
a template for you, and people are making
their own rendering of Sol Lewitt, this is
one you can go to it right now, and there's
renders in your browser, there's another one,
another one, another one.
And the great thing about them is that there
can be multiple versions of the same solution.
Because they have a little bit.
They have alliful ambiguity.
He did that intentionally the different aboutist,
different drafts people would interpret it
differently.
I encourage you to fork that Repo, give it
a star, because that helps and then it takes
about an hour, two hours depending on your
comfort withdrawing with code, and solves
them.
And then finally this is somethinge something
that you can do without any code at all, I
know that's kind of an outrayous proposal
at JSConf 2014, but that's the deal.
So this is a Swiss artist‑‑ a group
of artist they were inspired by Sol Lewitt.
They have art game, all you need are four
players, four sharpies, and many beers, and
each player takes a turn and what you see
there is that they're doing the first exercise
in the book, a cross hatching exercise and
by the time they're finished with it, you
get kind of a neat piece of hatched art.
This is a great thing to do with anyone, you
can do it with your partner, you can do it
with your kids, you can even do it with your
entyre company, everybody will have a different
perspective on how this art is generated.
I did this with 60 engineers at a company
in LA, it was neat they had it up on their
wall for months after ward.
That's a conditional design work book.
I love it.
They have about a dozen exercises in this
book, you can download it at conditional design.org
your can buy it.
If you ever see them, buy them a beer and
send me the bill.
This is great work and they deserve to be
reworded.
So those are some things to get started.
It's not the limit of things to get started.
We have all this great stuff like projection
mapping, which we see here, the demo scene
that Matthew talked about earlier, there's
Arduino, connect.
There's tons of things to do.
These are three little snacks for you to start
with, start with anything.
And the reason why we solve problems, the
technology is going to change but the problem
solving skills are not, if you take time to
abstract your problem solving skills, using
something like this, get to understand the
process of how you solve problems, I think
that's a skill you're going to be able to
use for a wrong time in your career, long
after like Angular, JavaScript becomes something
if new in five years.
JavaScript okay is not going anywhere, that's
not Blasmmy‑‑ go home, this is my Twitter
handle, my web site, my e‑mail, I want to
help, show me what you make, and let's get
started.
Thank you very much ( applause)